so i think the new business model for
creators is a business model to attack
the market with ip attack the market
with ip
what is the business model for
filmmakers today the business model for
filmmakers today
is
it's a complicated question because
the question could be
what should be the the business model
for filmmakers today
but but what is the
the the model for filmmakers today i
think still sits
wholly
in that traditional model of you know i
gotta go to the studio and i gotta you
know you know uh option my option my
script and go through the development
process and you know and go through that
whole thing there's the whole
traditional side of the business that's
still
moving along uh but now
on the outside of the studio system then
you're uh you're looking at a different
business model that is is more ip
focused and i think if you if you really
study the market and understand the way
the market works
it's about how do you launch and grow ip
and uh
and and this is this is not a new
concept because we've known for decades
that everything that we see on tv is
always based on a book and you know even
the the stuff that we know is the most
original we think is the most original
stuff we've ever we've ever uh uh you
know considered and we we love the
originality of this limited series or
this interesting film
98 of the time you trace it back and
it's based on a book and the reason it's
based on a book isn't because
hollywood's in love with books it's
because they love the pre-awareness that
the books bring they love the community
that's already built
for the book and it skews the risk
analysis into the favor of the filmmaker
when they say hey let's let's take this
book and let's make it a movie it's just
a lower risk investment and so uh so so
ip creation and establishing ip in the
market is has has always been a thing
and but now in the with the
proliferation of other platforms and the
the the democratization of other
platforms where normal people can have
access to these other platforms such as
podcast and
webtoon and uh what short stories on
wattpad uh
comic books things like that
now the business model for creators is
how to
take their ip and attack the market
in
whatever platform they can so that they
could establish a market presence grow
the community
of that around that ip actually get fans
and then once they have fans then maybe
down the road they go and shop this
thing for for film and television uh
because when you do that you can
actually have a conversation uh because
you you have something established in
the market and you have fans and you've
established pre-awareness and i think
pre-awareness is is is vital in in
today's market because of the high risk
economics of of filmmaking because the p
a budgets because the budge the the
production budgets are are just
increasing so much i mean you look at
you look at the lord of the rings series
on amazon they spent 250 million dollars
just for the rights and then they spent
450 million dollars in production for
one season of tv and so you're spending
three quarters of a billion dollars on a
season of television and so
they're not going to do that
with something that hasn't been
established in the market the only
reason they're comfortable with uh with
spending three quarters of a billion
dollars is because
lord of the rings is an established ip
in the market and that and there's a
legion of tolkien fans and and they've
tested the the previous the hobbit
movies and lord of the rings movies and
and it's been around for a zillion years
and all of a sudden it skews the risk
analysis into the favor of the studio
they said i think we can do it i mean
you look at the foundation series that's
coming out on on apple that apple's
releasing and uh that that that was a
series of books that's been around
forever uh and and a lot of people maybe
won't know that and think oh this is
just original filmmaking no it's
established i.p in the market but
but used to you could
you know the only way you could do that
is through a book but now like i said
you can you can do that in a variety of
different ways and so one of the most
option things in hollywood right now are
podcasts podcasts are wildly popular as
far as being optioned and you look at uh
what amazon did with homecoming uh not
beyonce homecoming but the other
homecoming with julia roberts uh the
the the drama series and that was a
podcast you look at something like night
fail there was a podcast you look at
what hbo max
they uh they greenlit the calm app tv
show i don't know if anybody you're
familiar with the com app the comm app's
been a top 10 app in the app store for
the last 10 years the meditation app
it's just a meditation app for that
promotes uh the proposed mental health
and keeps makes you calm and helps you
meditate and hbo max just green lit a tv
show based on the app
which
makes no sense
other than
there's a brand there and there's a
community there and there's
pre-awareness in the market they'll hire
a writer and they'll hire producers and
they'll hire talent that'll make it work
but what they were looking for is is
there the pre-awareness in the market
and you see something with angry birds
angry birds launched into the market not
as the animated films launched in the
market as a mobile game
and
so i think that is the new business
model for creators is how do i how do i
not wait for
netflix or amazon or universal pictures
or disney to to
give me permission
to make my dreams come true
i don't i don't want to wait for netflix
to give me permission to tell the story
that's in my heart
it it it you'll be waiting forever right
and and and you'll be deceived by the
fact that there are some people that
netflix does come and make their dreams
come true and they give them the big
giant check but but for every one person
that's waiting for that that it actually
works for you know there's there's you
know a hundred thousand people hundred
thousand filmmakers that
that never get that break
and it's not because they're less
talented it's just because it's a it's a
hard industry and it's competitive and
there's a lot of super talented people
out there and it's tough to be able and
and the line around netflix is you know
10 blocks long figuratively speaking
with people that want to get in netflix
right so so it's it you know
people are waiting for these studios
to give them permission to to follow
their heart and tell their story when i
say
that's
that's cool
but don't wait
or at least while you're waiting attack
the market
while you're waiting launch your ip in
the 10 or 15 or 20 ways that we have at
your fingertips at all time that you can
do for very little or zero money
like you know a podcast you can you can
take you can take your iphone and you
can download anchor an anchor is is a
free app on the app store that will
allow you to
hold up the phone to your ear and it
records your podcast in just into the
phone and then it distr and you put
bumper music and you can edit it and
then it distributes it into the the
apple podcast store and it puts it on
spotify all completely for free
and then you can use the the
distribution platforms and social media
and things like that to to get it in
front of people start building your
audience and you can actually tell the
story that you intel while you're
waiting on netflix
but the trick is then if you actually
grow the community of people that
that love your podcast love your story
uh and and you know are engaging with
your brand
you've increased your chances from
hearing from netflix because you've
actually created pre-awareness the
market right and you you accelerate i
mean i there was there was a there was
an ip that i had uh uh we we we sold we
sold to fox
it languished in development when the
turnaround we got it back and uh
we had played that game for seven years
trying to shop it finally got it shopped
wanted to turn around got it back seven
years
and i thought
what would have happened if i would we
would have been running a podcast the
entire time what would have been what
would have happened if i would we would
have had comic books in the market and
release self-published novels into the
market uh we wouldn't when it goes in
the turnaround we wouldn't be at zero
again we would have had fans and we
would have had a brand and we would have
had ip the film and television wouldn't
have worked the way we wanted it to work
and then we'd have to kind of reorganize
that but at least we would have done
some other things and attack the market
in a way and and not just wait for a
giant studio to give me a giant ed
mcmahon check and say i give you
permission to tell the story that you've
always wanted to tell and it's uh so so
i'm very
very bullish
on
encouraging filmmakers
don't wait
launch
launch launch use all the stuff that we
have all the tools in the toolbox to
launch the ip
if you know if you know
uh people that can produce music work
with them to maybe tell a story through
a song and launch that uh if you know
how to write a short story launch you
know launch that if you know how to do a
podcast do it that way uh do a web tune
do you know do do something
and uh one
it it helps you
not
be frustrated as you wait to hear back
from an agent and send it out query
letters and the whole game that we all
know which is i'm not saying that's bad
i'm saying okay let's do that but while
we do that let's do some other things so
you're not just sitting around waiting
to hear back from people you're actually
doing something right which keeps you
it just keeps you happy as a storyteller
to be able to tell your stories i mean i
you know
personally i found myself
years ago
as a writer
the thing the things that i wrote most
were pitch decks i found myself writing
more pitch decks than i were that i did
scripts and that was disconcerting to me
right because that's sort of what you
kind of fall into in hollywood is this
crazy game of just trying to like hustle
something and and and you're doing a lot
less creating and just a lot more
pitching right and so uh so you know
there's there's a i think there's an
artistic and a soulful benefit to
launching ip in the market just
satisfies you as you wait for the the
big guys to come and make your dreams
come true but then there's also a legal
benefit to it and so you know i consider
myself a recovering lawyer i started my
career as a lawyer uh
and almost completely recovered as a
lawyer but from a legal perspective
if if you can establish
an ip in the market
there's a lot greater chance of you
getting a better deal on the back end if
and when the studio comes and wants to
participate in into a feature film if
you just write a spec script and you go
and like like you know like filmmakers
do and like writers do and you go sell
that spec script and it's not based on
any pre-existing ip it's it's just an
original idea and you sell you settle
inspect say you get on the black list
and and they snatch it off the black
list and they they they give you a deal
that's awesome it's it's it's
by and large a wholesale acquisition
it's
we're taking the whole bucket of rights
and we'll give you a check that's a high
five handoff that you know you you go
off and you know we'll take this and
we'll go and make this movie but they
have all the rights to every
platform ever created and here forever
two will be created until the end of
time there's all those big lawyerly
clauses in there they own everything
right they take the whole deal
theoretically they give you a check to
make you feel better about that right
which sometimes
that makes you feel better other times
it doesn't um
but if you say publish a book
self-publish a book and and uh and that
book sells and you're able to then get
that to be turned into a movie
the deal that is then done is a
different deal it's then you have uh
what's called a split rights deal where
they come and license the right to adapt
the book into a movie
right so they take the film and
television rights
right but it's a license deal for the
film and television rights and you
maintain your other ip rights
video game comic books merchant you know
things like other things that you want
to create right and uh which is much
better in success of the movie
right or the tv show or whatever they do
then all these other rights become more
valuable and you've retained them
simply because you were able to
establish the ip in the market and you
didn't you didn't go to the studios
first right so so even if you don't want
to talk about the uh
the uh sort of the creative benefits of
attacking the market and being
aggressive with the ip and not waiting
right and being passive
as as your fake lawyer as for that that
i would give you this this legal advice
never just sell a spectrum to a studio
it's crazy just publish it self-publish
it as a book first now ten years ago
before you could really self-publish
or there wasn't really podcast and there
weren't really these other things
then what are you supposed to do the
only thing you could do is is just sell
it directly to a studio because not not
a lot of other other options right now
there are so many options it's uh it
makes it just doesn't make a lot of
sense to be able to go to them first you
just you're just
you're
misappropriated and losing sight of the
broader opportunity of your ip so so i
think the new business model for
creators is a business model to attack
the market with ip attack the market
with ip and when you when you generate
the pre-awareness of the community it's
going to create residual benefits that
is that are not only going to make you
more attractive to the studios but it's
actually going to help you retain more
and control more of the ip moving
forward
and from what i understand about this
new netflix series made yeah with
margaret quality um it it started as um
an article a woman who was in a homeless
shelter with her child she was cleaning
houses and she kind of wrote this thing
about hey what people don't know about
what i know about you from cleaning your
house and that took off and
then she did this book yeah and then and
now and now we have this this show
coming up sure i'm looking forward to
seeing it and again that was someone
that was
always wanted to be a writer had a lot
of tragic things happen and decided to
hunker down and sort of make the best of
it and look at now it's sure you know
that's a rags to riches story right
there and if she would have just written
that as a spec script
and then just started shopping that
around
i think we we would well we wouldn't be
having this conversation today because
because it would have gotten it would be
languishing in the crazy game that is
the spec
world of hollywood right she she was
able to take this and then launch it in
a different way let's write the article
let's let's do it let's launch it in a
different form let's then publish the
book let's let's do it as a blog let's
do something else right and and then we
we grow awareness we grow the
pre-awareness we we've we've actually
established the ip in the market and
then guess what especially when it
becomes popular then uh then then the
studios want to get involved and that
deal and i'm not privy to the the
specifics of the deal but but i would
guarantee that that deal that was made
for that particular uh that particular
ip
is a better deal than she would have got
if she would have written the spec
script and tried to sell that spectre at
first i don't think she would have sold
the spec grip to begin with
but in the event that she would have it
would have been a worse deal than what
she got now simply because she was able
to establish it in the market right but
see see this is the interesting thing
it's it's a paradigm shift with with
filmmakers typically filmmakers uh and
and
and screenwriters and listen i i include
myself in this umbrella so it we we
we want to focus on filmmaking and
screenwriting and and and we feel like
if i just write my five pages a day
everything's gonna work and i don't
wanna learn how to do a podcast like
that's not me i don't wanna learn how to
make a website i don't wanna i don't
wanna uh uh you know write short stories
i'm a screenwriter
right and
and
i wish i wish that person would have
been
born in 1978 and then you know was able
to be able to operate in you know late
80s 90s hollywood because uh because it
was just as a different market and you
could kind of you know specialize like
that um but uh but but it's just it's a
different market and and there's this
this uh there's this
hesitancy
for lack of a better word if if i say
that euphemistically there's this
hesitancy to broaden your scope of
creative to be able to launch
an ip in the market you feel like
you're you're doing something that's
less than screenwriting you're lowering
yourself to do a short story you're
lowering yourself to do a podcast
there's this this you know this this
artistic judgment and you feel like you
you and maybe you just judge yourself of
like man that this means that i'm if i
was good enough i'd be able to sell this
thing right and and you judge yourself
for it and and you shouldn't judge
yourself for that you it's it's there's
too much stuff out there and it's way
too competitive and uh
i think if if if creators and filmmakers
and screenwriters if they have the mind
of a of an entrepreneur who's who's
launching a consumer brand you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna approach this
whole thing differently because you talk
to any entrepreneur that that says i'm
gonna start a pizza shop
right uh and i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna open the pizza shop and and it's
gonna be great because i have this
family recipe of pizza i've been working
on uh like they are forced to learn
a hundred new skills in order to launch
that pizza shop
right you never hear somebody say uh i
want to launch my pizza shop with my
family recipe uh of pizza and i'm only
going to focus on making the pizza
i'm not going to learn how to do payroll
i'm not going to learn how to hire front
of house back house i'm not going to
learn how to order i'm not going to
learn about management i'm not going to
learn how to do the register i'm not
going to learn about anything else other
than pizza and that's it i'm just going
to focus on my pizza and as long as i
make good pizza everything will fall
into place
odds are that pizza shop will never open
right because of course
entrepreneurs know i want to do a pizza
shop i know how to make a good pizza
okay i still have to learn how to run
the register and i still have to learn
how to market the right way and i still
have to learn how to you know how how to
manage my staff and i still have to
learn how to order all the food from the
wholesalers and things like that you it
you're forced into
figuring out five or six new things that
you've never figured out before and
that's just part of being an
entrepreneur and every entrepreneur will
tell you that like you have to you're
forced to learn 100 new things
what are those 10 new things that we
need to learn as screenwriters and
filmmakers what are the 20 new things
that that that we can learn
as creators that can help us launch the
ip and and here's the good part here's
the here's the punch line that i think
is the greatest punch line of all time
it's all there
on the internet for free
youtube is the greatest educational uh
platform in the history of mankind if i
want to figure out how to change a
1987 volvo station wagons carburetor
there's probably a youtube video that's
going to walk me through it
we can
go to go to youtube go to google and say
how do i
how do i create a podcast
and there's 17 articles instantly or 17
videos that pop up you can go to
linkedin learning and and uh or or you
can go to you know
whatever like resource that you want to
use
and you can take the 7 to 10 to 27 hours
to figure it out and not that you can
connect with people that know how to do
it i had a buddy who he won the nichols
fellowship as a screenwriter right which
is a big deal nicholas is is a very
competitive um uh screenwriting
competition he won the nichols
fellowship he he pitched a movie to
paramount pictures as a result of
winning the the the nichols fellowship
he pitched the script to paramount
paramount said uh it was too risky
because it wasn't established in the
marketplace and they said we want you to
go and
create a comic book and launch it as a
comic book and if you sell 10 000 copies
of that comic book
come back to us and we'll make your
movie
so
he walked out of that meeting
super bummed not just because they
didn't make the movie but they said make
a comic book and guess what he was a
screenwriter he didn't know how to make
a comic book right which if this was
that would have been a big bummer
but because it was
he was able to go home
open up the laptop google how do i make
a comic book and you started reading and
he started finding out where the artist
hung out online and the artist
communities and art station and
deviantart and things like that he he
learned the production workflow the cost
of making a comic book how they were
distributed he just started researching
and he connected with an artist uh in a
like estonia or some europe eastern
european country that that that
he uh they decided to collaborate on
something they they scraped and put one
issue of a comic book together took them
months they put an issue of one issue of
a comic together and they they
distributed it digitally on amazon
and uh
made enough money from it to make an
issue too
and then they made enough money on it to
make an issue three and then they made
enough money on it to make it issue four
and then after issue four guess what
happened they got picked up by a small
independent publisher that said we'll
pay for the publishing of it right so
they did issue five and then after issue
five they're putting it all together as
a trade paperback all five issues
together and now four years later he's
right on the verge of his 10 000 unit
cell right and he says houston guess
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go back to
paramount pictures and tell them to make
my movie because i have to hit the ten
10 000 or the 10 000 sale mark right but
guess what i'm not going to stop selling
my comic book
why because it's an extra source of
revenue for me
and
i have a community of fans that love
this stuff right so why would i stop and
so now he self-identifies as not just a
screenwriter but he's a screenwriter
slash
comic book creator right he's you know
there's there's this there's this uh
this term called polymath right people
that are good at multiple things and we
typically lawed people in entertainment
that can do more right beyonce can sing
and she can dance and j lo can act and
sing and dance and and we always say all
these people are amazing they're
entrepreneurs and actors and singers and
creators and you know and we love that
about people we need to start looking at
ourselves as that because we have the
ability to do that and because all the
tools are in front of us so i think
that's the model that we have to hit is
is being willing to have that mindset
shift
of
i need to learn some more i need to
broaden my own skill set right and but
when i do it's going to open up a no new
world for me because i'm able to
establish my p my ip in the market